[Musica]
1975 siamo abitalia una sonnolenta
cittadina della california centrale dove
tutti si conoscono e la gente
lascio alle porte di casa aperte non
adesso però perché sono due anni che un
uomo entra nelle case ruba oggetti di
scarso valore e si dilegua verrà
definito il saccheggiatore di di sale
siamo nell'area invece di sacramento e
il 1979 siamo 400 km a nord divisa le
lunghe schiera di villette bianche dove
vive la borghesia medio alta
sono tre anni che un uomo terrorizza i
residenti sceglie le case delle giovani
coppie
entra di notte lega l'uomo e violenta la
donna poi si dilegua santa barbara 1986
siamo 600 chilometri a sud di sacramento
poco sopra los angeles
già nell cruz e l'ultima vittima di un
feroce assassino che in sette anni ha
ucciso e violentato uomini e donne
entra nelle loro case di notte nei
credits nel sonno mentre dormono per
questo motivo verrà definito in seguito
l'originale stalker notturno sono tre
uomini il saccheggiatore di risale lo
stupratore delli steve è l'originale
stalker notturno passano i mesi e gli
anni i casi non vengono risolti
si raffreddano diventano scatoloni nei
sotterranei delle stazioni di polizia
siamo orange county 1996 alcuni tecnici
della fbih ai stanno sistemando i
reperti biologici dei cosiddetti cold
cases i casi che non sono mai stati
risolti
quando non certo
punto si rendono conto di una cosa
incredibile il dna raccolto dalle scene
del crimine conservato per tutti questi
anni era lì davanti alloro ed era
identico i tre uomini il saccheggiatore
lo stupratore e lo stalker erano la
stessa persona
i casi vengono immediatamente connessi e
riaperti
purtroppo non basta la polizia ha in
mano il dna di quello che verrà definito
in seguito il golden state killer ma
caricandolo nel codes il database di
materiale genetico di materiale
biologico dei criminali negli stati
uniti
non c'è nessun match il caso si
raffredda di nuovo e questa volta per 22
lunghissimi anni 27 aprile di quest'anno
pochi mesi fa jones james d'angelo e un
pensionato sulla settantina sta uscendo
di casa per gettare la spazzatura quando
viene arrestato da una task force di
polizia ed fbi con l'accusa di essere i
golden state killer
l'uomo non aveva precedenti penali non
era mai stato arrestato e aveva preso in
meno di cinque multe in tutta la sua
vita come ha fatto allora la polizia
a rivelare l'identità del golden state
killer un investigatore
poco prima della sua pensione aveva
deciso di caricare il profilo genetico
del golden state killer su un sito
internet geldman un sito dove chiunque
può caricare il proprio profilo genetico
per scoprire qualcosa sul suo albero
genealogico questa volta c'è un match
probabilmente un parente alla lontana la
polizia può isolare quindi che
attraverso il dna del parente
restringere il campo incrociare i dodici
identikit che aveva e con le prove
raccolte arrivare all'arresto di joseph
james d'angelo un ex poliziotto
già set james d'angelo non è stato
catturato perché ha commesso un errore e
neanche per uno di quei casi alla
sherlock holmes jones james d'angelo è
stato catturato
perché un suo parente alla lontana aveva
deciso di caricare il suo profilo
genetico su un sito internet innocua
mente è gratis
questo è incredibile anche per questo
momento storico anche se lo guardiamo il
passato più recente
e già perché quello che credevamo di
sapere su noi stessi di solito si basava
su ipotesi teorie più o meno fondate e
supposizioni spesso in contrasto l'una
con l'altra
poi arriva il 2003 e in quell'anno che
completiamo uno dei progetti di ricerca
scientifica più importanti della storia
dell'umanità lo human genome project per
la prima volta riusciamo ad analizzare
completamente il dna di un essere umano
e gli scienziati iniziarono a notare una
cosa è tra le cose più interessanti che
notarono fu che se pur convinti di
essere una specie ipersofisticato
eravamo e continuiamo a essere molto
simili ai topi geneticamente 95 per
cento per essere preciso e io davvero
vorrei dirglielo e razzisti questo
ma torniamo a quelle tre lettere di n a
7,6 miliardi di persone condividono il
99,9 per cento del dna quello che rende
me è diverso da voi ed a tutti gli altri
è contenuto in quello 0,1 per cento e
quello 0,1 per cento che deciderà il
colore dei miei occhi la grandezza del
mio naso o lo spessore dei miei capelli
ok non vi è venuta bene
quello che abbiamo scoperto sul dna è
incredibile perché è una molecola che di
fatto è piena di enigmi
pensate solo il 2 per cento di tutto il
codice genetico ci porterà a una
proteina il restante 98 viene definito
dna spazzatura perché sembra non
container e nessuna informazione o
almeno questo è quello che crediamo oggi
che conosciamo ancora molto poco di
questa molecola un'altra cosa
incredibile di questo dna e lo spazio
che riesce a occupare piccolissimo con
la sua forma a doppia elica
pensate se a lunghissimo tutto il codice
genetico dell'uomo in un unico filamento
riusciremmo a coprire la distanza tra la
terra e il sole 66 volte andata e
ritorno
un'altra cosa incredibile del dna e che
il 40 per cento di tutto il dna che è
contenuto nel tratto gastrointestinale
di noi esseri umani non appartiene agli
esseri umani
in realtà non appartiene neanche ai
funghi ai batteri ei virus analizzare
questa molecola sembrava come affrontare
uno di quei grandi enigmi difficili da
risolvere alcuni dissero impossibile è
troppo costoso
e in effetti quando completammo lo human
genome project nel 2003 sequenziare
analizzare il dna costava 100 milioni di
dollari
non proprio il generico che chiedereste
alla farmacia sotto casa ma le nostre
generazioni stanno vivendo un momento di
straordinaria accelerazione tecnologica
questo vuol dire non solo che alcune
tecnologie crescono molto incapacità
esponenzialmente come dicono e morti ma
vuol dire anche che i prezzi crollano
molto velocemente e oggi analizzare il
dna costa meno dello smartphone che
avete in tasca
questo è il momento in cui quelle tre
lettere dy.na hanno smesso di essere
qualcosa di legato strettamente alla
medicina
alle genetica e hanno iniziato ad essere
qualcos'altro il codice del futuro
vedete quando parliamo di scienza in
generale la fantasia è quasi meglio
della realtà quasi perché quello che
abbiamo scoperto negli ultimi anni sul
dna ci ha fatto imboccare sentieri che
neanche il miglior film di fantascienza
e oggi con voi mi piacerebbe imboccare
due di questi sentieri chi ha mai
sentito parlare di chris per cast mine
non è una stella non è un pianeta e
nonostante il nome fantastico non è
neanche l'astronave del film alien chris
per casna in è una tecnologia volta alla
modifica genomica gli scienziati la
usano per modificare il dna di essere
del tutto sincero non è qualcosa di
veramente nuovo
i batteri la utilizzano da sempre per
difendersi dai virus
e già perché anche i batteri hanno dei
nemici e quando entrano in contatto con
il dna virale hanno pochissimo tempo per
combatterlo
non avendo degli anticorpi ma è la
natura regalato loro un sistema
immunitario adattivo chris per che è
capace di individuare quel dna virale
legarsi effettuare un taglio e
distruggerlo gli scienziati hanno
iniziato quindi a utilizzare questa
tecnologia su vari organismi scimpanzé
con roditori e anche sull'uomo
il meccanismo è il medesimo chris per
può scegliere uno specifico settore del
dna riconoscerlo legarsi effettuare un
taglio come farebbero un paio di forbici
in quel momento il dna potrebbe
includere un nuovo filamento di dna
oppure semplicemente ridursi come
farebbe la ferita nel processo di
guarigione è normale adesso immaginate
se però se in quello specifico tratto di
dna che io ho tagliato c'è un
informazione genetica che porta una
patologia grave come la fibrosi cistica
o il morbo di alzheimer in futuro questa
tecnologia potrebbe riaccendere la
speranza di curare malattie a oggi
mortali
il secondo sentiero che voglio prendere
con voi riguarda invece i big data
beh negli ultimi anni abbiamo prodotto
una quantità da di dati talmente elevata
che in molti si sono chiesti e adesso
dove le archiviamo gli hard disk del
futuro non avranno ovviamente vita
semplice perché da uno studio ibm emerge
un dato agghiacciante il 90 per cento
dei dati prodotti e archiviati in tutta
la storia dell'umanità
lo abbiamo prodotto negli ultimi due
anni nonostante gli hard disk e siano
sempre più capienti e ovvio che la
velocità con cui miglioriamo quella
tecnologia e la velocità con cui invece
creiamo dati sono assolutamente diverse
e sapete già la risposta alla domanda
che sto per farvi dove archivieremo
tutti i nostri dati in futuro sempre
quelle tre lettere di n
ha sempre più fantascientifico è sempre
più realtà
useremo il dna come gli hard disk ora il
codice della vita il codice genetico è
dato da un'alternanza di basi azotate
quattro lettere a cgt adenina citosina
guanina e timina il codice dei computer
invece è un'alternanza di numeri 2
precisamente 0 e 1 il sistema binario
ora semplificando molto direi che
basterebbe tradurre le lettere i numeri
ad harvard ci hanno già provato nel 2012
hanno salvato 52 mila libri in un
singolo filamento di dna nel 2016 è
stata la volta delle mighty che ha
alzato il tiro ha voluto salvare una gif
animata salvata in un organismo portata
in un altro laboratorio ri analizza
le gif erano uguali al 90 per cento
non ci credete ecco a voi la
ricostruzione l'originale e quella
ricostruita dai batteri il 2017 è stato
invece la volta della columbia
university decidono di salvare in un
frammento di dna un sistema operativo un
coupon di amazon qualche file sparso è
un film francese del 1895
beh quando sono andati a riprenderli
erano uguali quasi al cento per cento ma
perché usare il dna come archiviazione
di dati
beh sicuramente per lo spazio perché in
un grammo di dna siamo capaci di salvare
215 milioni di gigabyte potremo
archiviare tutta la storia dell'umanità
in una stanza e poi il dna tour a
centinaia di anni se non di più
sicuramente molto di più di un normale
hard disk qualche mese fa ho letto una
notizia
una notizia di quelle bizzarre in
messico attacca storico gruppo
britannico avevano deciso di celebrare
il ventesimo anniversario del loro album
più famoso mezza nen salvandolo nel dna
ora se non vi avessi raccontato tutto
questo avrebbe l'area di una fake news
non lo è perché i massive attack hanno
preso il loro album lo hanno ridotto in
un file da 15 megabyte inserito in
920.000 filamenti di dna è salvato in
cinquemila sfere di vetro infinitesimali
se io avessi raccontato questo al made
dieci anni fa non ci avrei mai creduto
e ovvio che tutto quello che vi ho
raccontato oggi pone l'accento su
questioni difficili anche da giudicare
ad esempio il baio hecking su youtube
iniziano a circolare i primi video
tutorial di ragazzi che insegnano come
modificare i propri geni ingegneria
genetica fatta in casa
giusto o sbagliato e poi c'è
l'eugenetica programmare i nostri figli
per essere sani forti belli quasi
immortali non è forse questo il sacro
graal della nostra generazione ma è
anche quello che sognavano le dittature
più feroci del novecento
e allora è giusto o sbagliato e poi c'è
l'islanda dove non nascono più bambini
con la sindrome di down
perché i test genetici sono talmente
economici che le coppie riescono a
scoprire per tempo se il proprio figlio
avrà un'altra percentuale di avere
questa sindrome
giusto o sbagliato quali dico la mia
sbagliato perché i figli sono tutti sani
e tutti uguali torniamo per un secondo
solo al golden state killer difficile
non gioire per l'arresto di un criminale
che ha lasciato dietro di sé una
striscia spessa di sangue e dolore per
quasi mezzo secolo
però gli il golden state killer è stato
arrestato perché un suo parente alla
lontana che lui neanche conosceva ha
deciso un giorno di caricare il suo
profilo su un sito internet il suo
profilo genetico i confini della privacy
stanno letteralmente svanendo
giusto o sbagliato
non credo siano questioni facili da
affrontare ma credo siano questioni
urgenti e per questo che servono e sono
necessarie organizzazioni che sti milano
stimolino il dibattito su questi temi
che portino la consapevolezza degli
impatti che queste tecnologie possono
avere nella nostra vita e nella nostra
società
anche per questo è nata in pack school e
per questo abbiamo incontrato più di 8
mila persone in meno di due anni siamo
di nuovo di fronte a un bivio e questa
volta non avremo molto tempo per
decidere
useremo questa tecnologia per fare del
male armi batteriologiche soldati
onnipotenti sperimentazioni genetiche
segrete o lo faremo per fare del bene
curando la fame nel mondo curando
malattia oggi mortale migliorando la
vita di alcuni esseri umani siamo liberi
di essere grandi quale sarà il sentiero
che sceglieremo di percorrere grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]